carnival and welcome to Dara Salaam in
Tanzania I've just had one of the most
mind-blowing weeks of my entire life
hanging out with my mum and we've saved
the children and now I get to tell you
about it so first I met a guy called
Franco Pater at his home here in Daraa
Salaam along with his little brother and
his father William basically I was
thrown into a world that is utterly
different to what I'm used to at home
and spent the first day feeling a little
bit shell-shocked Frank is a pretty
inspiring guy he's 15 he's the young
ambassador for Save the Children here
and when he was younger he was one of
those starving kids in Africa that we
hear so much about to be more specific
Frank used to suffer from malnutrition
so he did have a little bit of food
enough to survive but not enough to grow
up healthily as a result his growth was
stunted and so he's much smaller than he
should really be at his age and although
he seemed to me to be a very intelligent
guy malnutrition also affected his brain
growth so he could have been even
smarter than he currently is the issues
of hunger and malnutrition are by the
way the reason that I'm here Save the
Children invited me to come along to
support the if campaign which aims to
make this year the beginning of the end
for world hunger which obviously I've
been supportive however Frank isn't a
malnutrition statistic he's a person
like he does campaign against hunger
because it's obviously an issue that's
very important to him but he also likes
jazz music and supports Arsenal and
wants to be a journalist when he grows
up but most importantly to me over the
week that I've spent with him despite
the language barrier he's become a
friend of mine even by the end of the
first day he was already calling me my
good friend mr. Charlie so after Frank
was nice enough to show me and my mum
around his house where his dad works
shining shoes and his school as well we
all got on this tiny little plane the
smallest plane I've ever been on in my
entire life to Tenga and we traveled to
the region of couric way to visit a
couple of villages where the rest of
Frank's family lived and where he grew
up so I think that we must have met
every single possible member of Frank's
extended family while we were there and
I know that you're not meant to pick
favorites but I couldn't help but fall
in love a little bit with his
grandmother Bibi
when Danny Barney wait what do Cappy
Aaron Frank were both kind enough to
show me or my mom how to make googly
which is a very simple and common staple
food here and it's basically just flour
and water heat it up a bit and stirred
that's it I quite liked it honestly but
as you can probably guess it's not
exactly gonna fulfill your five a day
sometimes you're able to have other more
nutritious things with it we had some
dried fish but vegetables work as well
and if they're really lucky they might
get some meats but even then maximum
that they get is maybe two meals a day
and that's just based on what they can
get their hands on for me the experience
of going to the villages was a little
hard to get my head around honestly
because compared to what I'm used to
they really don't have that much but as
a result they're so incredibly thankful
for everything they do have in their
lives they're so happy despite all of
the hardships they have to go through
and it's just it's just so inspiring and
so lovely I just feel incredibly honored
that I got to meet all of these lovely
people and that they invited me into
their lives with such open arms and now
I just don't want them to have any
problems
anyway that's just the first two days
I've done so much more stuff on this
trip including getting food poisoning
which I have now yay so I'm going to
save the rest for a second video until
then the Santos owner thank you very
much and I will encourage you to check
out enough food if not org if you'd like
more information about all this while
you wait for me so goodbye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
this is my faith on my head on my
shoulders with eyes and a mouth and a
nose